c'est une urgence qui sert les zones
chaudes du centre-ville de montréal
reste que notre dame est sortie de la
crise qui l'a frappé l'an dernier
les infirmières avaient dénoncé
publiquement la charge de travail est
supportable depuis la direction a réagi
une vingtaine d'infirmières auxiliaires
ont été embauchés
infirmières auxiliaires dalila des
ligues appuie les infirmières comme
fatoumata diallo la douleur elle est à
combien services de lille a rempli les
tâches de base comme les prises de sang
et les signes vitaux ce qui laisse plus
de temps aux infirmières pour le travail
plus complexe
il arriver des renforts a permis de
réduire le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire il y a presqu'un an j'étais
obligé de retenir cinq personnes pour la
part de travail suivant alors
qu'aujourd'hui bien écouter des on
appelle ces dts au j'en ai presque pull
québec a distribué 1900 bourses d'études
pour former plus d'infirmières
auxiliaires dans toutes les régions du
québec on va prendre la pression à
l'hôpital jean talon on soigne aussi le
personnel infirmier mais ici la solution
passe par l'ajout d'adjointe
administrative comme claudia anonyme
claude est ce que tu peux m'appeler pour
un électro instaload ya est arrivée en
renfort avec trois autres agente
administrative
la semaine dernière elle fait du travail
clérical et de l'accompagnement ce qui
donne plus de temps aux infirmières je
peux un club plus pour la passante je
vais l'écouter plus qu'on pouvait plus
se permettre de faire en ayant des
tâches administratives sans québec pense
aussi que former plus de personnel de
soutien fonctionne on veut aller
chercher trois mille agen 3 mille
bourses d'études ont été offertes trois
mois plus tard 1900 personnes en ont
profité un soutien financier essentiel
pour la mère de famille arrivée de
guinée l'an dernier
actif claudia était comptable dans son
pays d'origine mais elle est quand même
heureuse d'effectuer ici un travail
moins prestigieux au personnel du
domaine de la santé a pour en traiter
premier d'aider de sauver des vies donc
je vais faire partie de cette équipe là
je voudrais une fois à la maison savoir
que j'ai pu apporter mon aide à
quelqu'un québec souhaite susciter
plusieurs centaines d'autres vocation
semblable au cours des prochains mois un
outil de plus pour tenter de relancer le
réseau de la santé pas de compte à
présent dans beaucoup ici david
gêne-t-il et radio canada montréal